- Night, night.
- Jayson. Jayson!
Jayson! Focus!
It’s finally reached BeanTown.
The announcement from old man Silver everyone’s been talking about.
[Heraldic instrumentals]
- As the sun sets on the great LeBron,
the time has come to find a new face of our league.
Which one of you will prove your worth?
- Hey, you know who’d be a wicked good face of the league?
Modern-day Larry Bird.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-  Yes, sir!
- Wicked pissah.
- [Jaylen Brown:] How quickly they forget about us.
- [Jayson Tatum:] How quickly they forget about me.
- You?! Being selfish won't win us a ring of influence.
- You're only saying that because we—
- Got embarrassed. [Chuckling]
- It’s a troll.
- Worse...it’s a Joel.
♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
- Remember my game plan, Joel. No need to charge—
[Quickening footfalls]
[Exploding]
- Spacing.
[Quickening footfalls]
[Fighting]
- Bill Simmons shouldn't get an MVP vote.
- A trash-talker!
I thought there weren’t many of his kind left.
Jayson, I need you to—
- Oh, no. Embiid got in his head!
- [Chuckling]
Rent-free.
- If I took him out,
I could be the face of the league. Imagine:
[Quickening footfalls]
every man, woman and child
wearing a Jaylen Brown jerse—
[Gasping]
[Metal on metal screeching]
The Traveler.
Maybe I'm not...him. Jayson—
you're HIM. It's your team!
Be selfish. Be selfish…
[Electric sizzling]
- I haven't seen this in years.
It’s Mamba Mode! Stop him!
Goodbye, traveler.
One day you won't disappear when we all need you.
[Crash of hard landing]
- I can’t lose. I’m the best center in the league!
- Too bad it's a Wings League now.
[Screeching]
- Come back, Jimmy!
[Thud]
- I told you to take out that blimp.
- Hey, look, I didn’t shoot a powerball, like, all summer.
- Gentlemen, we WILL remain the face of the game.
- But we must do everything we can
to stop them.
Leave no stone unturned.
Before they become
too powerful.
[Triumphant music]
- [Grunting]
I'm back...on...top!
[Sun shuriken whirring]
[Splashing, sizzling]
- OK, you've had your shot. It's my time now.
- Luka?! If anyone's taking the
MVP idol from Jokic,
it's the winner of last year's one seed.
[Chiming]
- And how'd that work out for you? Huh?
[Fire igniting and water swirling]
[Laughing]
[Thundering]
- Wow!
The wonders of this strange land
never cease to amaze!
[Crashing]
You guys coming?
[Steady footsteps]
[Giannis:] Ah, man. Jokic does everything for
1.6-Kilometer-High City.
- This is why an elite fighter like you—
or me—must stop him from getting a third idol.
- Oh. So you're on Giannis's level now?
- [Luka]: Hahaha. OK.
[Whooshing]
- This is the closest I've been to a real trophy.
- Don’t! Jokic’s MVPs are rigged!
[Earth rumbling]
- [Luka and Devin]: Ahh!
- [Giannis]: Whee!
Oh. Another Giannis wall.
[Dribbling]
[Fire igniting]
- Point God, show me the way.
[Quickening footfalls]
[Gasp] Chris?
[Footfalls fading]
[Sigh] Deandre?
[Water dripping]
- Ah, well. I am used to being alone.
- [Menacing laughing]
- He's...here.
[Striking dynamite fuse]
- Hello.
- [Screaming]
- Here we go.
[Hook whirring]
[Steady footsteps]
- Stop hiding the MVP away in the mountains!
It belongs in a bigger market!
- Are we really doubling in open combat?
- Almost ready.
[Hook still whirring]
- I have many weapons in my arsenal.
[Dynamite sizzling and exploding]
[Warping]
- Ow! In the back? Who does that?
[Brand sizzling]
- Wet.
[Hammer thudding]
[To himself] He can sense where I am without looking.
I don't know if I can beat him without help.
[Earth bursting]
- [Powerful echoing] I am here for the idol.
Aye, man. This place is very nice!
[Water swirling]
- Ahhh!
- I will not be cooled off!
[Hammer thuds]
[Bursting]
- Goodbye!
- You had one job, Joker.
The Association's displeased.
[Nuggets whooshing]
[Chuckling] You know I live online.
Channel your rage at stopping these targets.
[Suspenseful music]
- Hmm.
[Joyful, playful music]
[Chill music]
- Ja!
- Hey, it’s Ja!
- Best out of his draft class!
- Oh, and Dillon Brooks!
- Man, I haven't seen Grit City this happy
since we switched Gasols.
- Hopefully I can be a good face
of the league for everyone.
[Siren buzzing]
[Townspeople panicking]
- What’s going on?
[Earth rumbling]
- Z...Zion!
- ROARRRR!
- [Dillon Brooks:] He’s got a new body.
[Evil laughing]
- ROAR!
- [Townsperson:] Oh, no! A titan with clothes on! Run!
- ROARRR!
-[Ja to himself:] Why is everyone so excited about Zion?
He hasn't really done any-
- ROAR!
- Dillon, get the Gritizens to safety!
[Ja to himself:] According to the overly detailed
diagram in my head,
nothing can stop Zion once he gets
through the perimeter.
- Don't worry. There's strength in numbers.
[Zion evil laughing]
- I still remember your weakness.
[Zion groaning]
[Gasps]
Even his kicks have changed!
Time to get flashy.
[Zion groaning]
The Association! It’s controlling him!
- ROARRRRR!
- Zion! It’s not just you against me!
This is bigger than that.
Remember the code!
- [Young Ja:] Zion, let’s promise to always be best friends.
- [Young Zion:] Promise! Now let’s go destroy
some fellow children.
[Shoes malfunctioning]
- The...code...
Spoiler alert: I was in there the whole time.
Whew.
Thanks, bro. They really tried to pit us against each other.
- Those old heads stay controlling the narrative.
- We gotta fight back.
Follow me.
[Tense music]
- Once Ja and Zion take each other out,
nothing will be in our way.
- [Chuckling] Yeah, nothing.
[Steady footsteps]
- Are we sure we want to activate...him?
- The Association headquarters are in The Holly Woods.
So we attack them where it hurts.
[Machine-like sounds]
[Upbeat music]
- [Charles Barkley:] The rising young stars are finally
fighting the old heads.
They're even taking down some legends from
within their own ranks.
There's no doubt a new class of heroes has risen up.
And ain't no way LeBron and those bus riders
taking out them kids.
Take them out to dinner maybe.
- Look at you. Already talking about food.
- I know you not talking!
All you talk about is barbecue chicken!
- At least I got rings.
- Ahhhhh!
- Thank you to the Salt Lakes for welcoming us to All-Hero Weekend.
As a special treat, taverns will be open till 8 p.m.
- I've never got so many cheers!
I'm so excited.
- Why's Steph here?
Everyone knows I was brought in to replace him.
- He thinks he can replace me.
Cute.
[Growling]
- Look, LeBron's courting the second-hottest young guard.
[Whispering]
- But King, you already have DLo.
- LeBron, step away from the impressionable young star.
- Thanks, Dame. I almost had to go to a place
with pressure and expectations.
- I've battled too many superteams.
Some less super than others.
And I vow no superteams will form this All-Hero Weekend.
- Not this loyalty s--t again.
[Saxophone Rat squeaks]
- Hmm.
- I've used it many times, it's never failed me.
- LeBron! Aw, did I ruin another one of your trades?
- [Chuckling] Maybe it's me, or maybe it's you.
- [Groaning] [Wall crumbles]
- I know you think you clutch.
I'll show you clutch.
- Dame, calm down.
You're not supposed to activate it.
Not at All-Hero Weekend.
- [Announcer:] Welcome back to the celebrity All-Hero game.
Post Malone struggles down the court, and-
[Energy burst]
- Oh, nice beam.
- It's... Dame Time.
May God have mercy on us all.
[Whispering]
- [Dame:] No. More. Hand covering mouth...
[Energy charging]
Whispering things!
Bombs away! [Blasting]
- [Grunting]
[Muffled explosions]
I knew this would happen.
Before I came here, I knew this would happen.
- [Echoing] Sixteen bars.
[Wooshing]
- Dame, you're right about superteams.
Everyone should follow the old ways of heartbreaking losses.
- Heh.
[Glass shattering]
- Hah!
[Sand cascading]
- Sorry, Dame.
You were destroying the Salt Lakes,
And none of us wanna be part of that rebuild.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:] Wow!
Best All-Hero Weekend yet.
- Nice bag of tricks you got there.
- Woah, careful. No superteams.
[Laughing]
- [LeBron:] I've used it many times,
It's never failed me.
- All hail the Beam.
All hail the Beam.
- You may be benched.
Worshipers of the Beam,
it has been my pleasure to shepherd in a triumphant new era,
where, with every victory, the Beam grows stronger.
- All hail the Beam.
- Tonight, we shall summon the Almighty Beam,
allowing us to blot out the Western sky with its beauty.
Never again will Sac Town be thrust back into darkness.
[Alarm buzzing]
An intruder!
It can’t be...
- The prodigal son has returned!
Tyrese!
- I’ve come to shut off that damn Beam!
[Phone ringing]
- [Hield:] You ready for that sweet revenge?
- [Haliburton:] I’m just focused on passing right now.
But yes!
- Brother Haliburton!
Have you come to embrace the Beam?
That’s rude.
Very well.
- Beam, grant us the power of the pistol offense.
Dang corner shooters.
Buddy!
- Haha! No one shoots faster than me.
- Wait, I'm new.
I don't know what I'm doing!
- I'm getting too old for this.
I’m too young for this!
- Nothing like homemade Red Velvet.
- Now we summon the Almighty Beam.
- [Haliburton:] You’re in my spot.
- It’s Haliburton. Run!
- There are no spots in the eyes of the Beam.
[Gong]
- Look into the Beam, Tyrese!
- Never!
[Beeping]
- [Fox:] No!
- Yo.
- The...Beam?
- I go by many names.
Some call me the Almighty Beam.
Some call me stupid and ironic.
I hear you've come to destroy me.
Why?
- I...wanted revenge for being cast out...
and to prove to everyone I’m not a fake hero.
- Wally Szczerbiak is everyone now?
You were a hero here.
And you are a hero in Indiana-opolis.
Just because the beam shines doesn't mean you don't shine.
You need to...find your own beam.
- Find my own beam.
[Ringing]
- [Hield:] You ready for that sweet revenge?
Where are you going?
- That’s someone else’s problem.
Let’s find our own beam.
- I was not expecting that answer to be that deep.
You good, bro?
- The Beam from the north is too powerful!
We must offer up a sacrifice to protect the cap!
- Oh, whoa! Whoa! Wait!
Collapse? There is no collapse!
We can make this work!
Just shoot us an opening, Ben.
-I...I...can't.
-I figured this moment would come.
-You figured this moment would come?!
You brought me here!
-I did what I was supposed to do.
-Kyrie, no!
Don’t leave me with these scrubs!
-Luckily, you were able to join this superteam, right?
-So is this like, ya'll's downtown or...?
-No, this is the Nash Path.
The quickest way to the tournament.
And where I can finally beat...him.
-That’s them, all right.
Luka’s carrying all the weight.
Attack!
-Look out!
-Oh, phew. It's just the Suns.
Thought it was refs.
Thank you.
-Wait...
It’s Kyrie.
And he’s actually planning on participating!
-Kevin, you must relax.
-Relax?! There is no relax, champ.
I’m on 10!
-OK, what's the game plan?
-Look, I'm not the savior here.
I’m watching just like everyone else.
-Good thing it's just my sons.
Hello, Book!
It’s Daddy Luka!
-Totally legitimate Warriors rings: GO!
[Rings flash]
[Water crashes]
[Energy balls blast]
-Hey! Y'all are shooting more than me.
-[sigh] Deandre...
-Not fair! I don’t wanna be here! Hmph!
-Looks like the odds are...even.
-Ugh! You and your numbers!
-Too hot...
[Energy ball whirrs]
TO HANDLES!
[Energy ball explodes]
-Ooh!
-Illegal powerball.
He took three steps!
Doesn’t count!
[Voice echoes]
[Record rewinding]
-Man...snitch.
-Well, I’ve done my role.
[Guitar sting]
-Come on, Russ. I mean, Steph. I mean, Kyrie. I mean, Book.
-You handle Kevin.
I’ve got this!
[Screaming]
-Isolation Chamber!
[Punching noises]
-You started it!
-No! You started it!
-Ow, my groin!
-I can’t believe what you said.
-You’ll have to be more specific.
-You said you “did what you were supposed to do.”
Did that include betraying your best friend?
You don’t have to answer.
Your silence speaks volumes.
Easy Money Mid-Range!
[Energy barrage blasting]
-Invisible Defender!
[Both yelling]
[Somber violin]
-Kyrie, no!
Don’t leave me with these scrubs!
-[Yelling] Huh?
-Don’t you see?
I saved you.
I saved you because...
I may wanna join the Suns next year.
-No, Kyrie.
Not again.
I mean, well...maybe?
If you—but, no.
-Come on.
For some reason the Mavs have been terrible since I got here.
-I mean, yeah, but...
-What? Um...
-[Laughing]
While they focus on their little rivalry,
the No. 1 seed can go straight to Playoff Mountain.
- Wooo! Knicks take Playoff Mountain!
- We’re going from the base camp to our face on a stamp, jueard!
- Bing bong! Yeah! We still do that!
- Hello! It’s your cool dad, Adam Silver.
Welcome to the Eastern Face of Playoff Mountain!
Each team will traverse their own path,
finding opponents on their way to the summit,
where the champion will take on the best of the Western Face.
Please, make your way to your assigned path.
- Hell yeah! I'm hype! Let's go!
-Ahhh!
-Chill, bro. The strongest heroes of the East Lands are all here.
[laughing]
[beep]
- On your mark...
get set...
[beep]
Ball!
[starting tone]
- Slow down!
If we get lost I'm gonna get blamed and sent away!
Relax, I was brought here to guide you.
I think we need to go–
- I'm doing things my way! Rahhhh!
- [sigh]
- M-m-m-maybe, maybe we should turn around.
- Paul George writes that everywhere.
Let's find our first opponent.
- Come out and fight!
Looks like we got a bye.
- Uh...
Uh, guys?
- Huh?
- Looks like the only thing stopping us from playoff success...
is ourselves!
- [RJ:] Ahh!
[shrill laughter]
- All right, here’s what we do.
I take out all three of them! Rah!!
- Julius! Slow down the pace!
- Necessary spin move!
- Unnecessary spin move!
- The Shadow Knicks have all our moves,
including our flaws.
Which means
Shadow RJ shouldn’t be able to shoot from there!
- Hey! Not true!
[power blast]
[power charging]
- W-w-whoa!
- Careful!
Spikes!
- I’ve put up with a lot,
but this is the Knicks team that finally breaks me!
- Every year it’s something.
- I knew we shouldn't have given up on Reddish!
- Maybe New York is a Nets town?
- Too...far.
- [evil laughter]
- [grunt]
- You’re...under...sized!
- I’m the same height as Donovan Mitchell!
-[Evil laughter] You can’t defeat us!
We’re the Knicks!
We’re already defeated!
- And we by far...
- have more demons...
- than anyone else here!
Playoff pressure!
- Too...much...pressure...
I’m out.
- [Evil laughter] Collapsing in crunch time?
The Knicks are so predictable.
- Predictable? These Knicks?
Haha! Now Julius!
- Jump...
pass!
- Haha!
- [groaning]
He left his feet! That should never work!
You can’t escape me forever!
I have facial recognition software!
[blast]
- Looks like your plan worked.
- All we needed was some heart.
- Sorry I’m late.
- En garde!
Ah! It's just the Knicks.
This should be an easy fight.
- Trust us, it’s harder than you think.
- Who will reach the top of Playoff Mountain
and lay claim to the new face of the league?
- Hell if I know.
I just know they get paid a hell of a lot more than when I was a hero.
Also my playoff prediction:
Wizards and the great Bradley Beal win it all.
- Shut up, Chuck!
I’m trying to wrap up the season!
- Uh oh! Rebound!
- Ahh! Not the face! My endorsements!
- [Narrator:] Once every generation...
a new star arrives.
- [Spaceship:] Undesirable destination confirmed.
- [Laughing] C'est super.
- [Narrator:] And everyone prepares for him.
- Shaquillum O'Nealus!
- [Narrator:] He can turn another young star
into a second fiddle.
He can build somethin'
out of all those bricks you've been pilin' up.
He can restart a fanbase's engine.
And finally answer...
all your tough questions.
He can even stop the greedy from hoardin'.
And maybe,
just maybe, he could stop our drought.
- Bonjour!
Which lucky souls has won the Wemby lottery?
- [Gregg Popovich:] And if he doesn't land here...
I mean, I’ll take a flier on Scoot. I don't care.
I’m gonna live forever.